there's a lot of things that happen in
the world that just leave you scratching
your head and one of them happened
yesterday Tesla literally the company
that ushered in the electric vehicle
Revolution they got kicked out of the s
p ESG Index this is laugh out loud funny
just another example of the clown world
that we're living in of course if you
ask the s p indexers why'd you kick them
out here's what they said well Tesla may
be playing in its part and taking fuel
powered cars off the road it has fallen
behind its peers when examined through a
wider ESG lunge now of course all that
corporate speak it sounds real good
makes you want to Pat yourself on the
back especially if you wear a suit and
title work every day but Elon Musk the
world's richest man armed with a Twitter
account and willing to speak his mind he
wasn't gonna let the irony pass by and
so he started tweeting and he didn't
stop all day first he said Exxon is
rated top 10 best in the world for
environment social and governance ESG by
S P 500 while Tesla didn't make the list
ESG is a scam it has been weaponized by
phony social justice Warriors but that
wasn't it he then went on to go ahead
and just literally tag the s SMB and say
that the s p Global ratings has lost
their integrity and then of course
there's plenty of other people that sort
of Pile in we can see here that Mark
Andreessen came out and he said dirty
clothes or ESG wait what is he talking
about well Dan McArdle said clothes
dryers in the United States use more
energy than all Bitcoin mining so not
doing your laundry must be very ESG if
you incorrectly believe Bitcoin mining
is so bad and then to add salt to the
wound Elon came out and he said that he
thinks ESG is literally the devil
incarnate I mean laugh out loud funny in
terms of the world's richest man using
memes to absolutely decimate the ESG
movement now naturally what we're
watching is literally a group of people
who started the ESG movement they
actually had good intentions they wanted
to do right by the environment they
wanted people to be more aware of it but
what's occurs that a loud minority has
hijacked this these are just extremists
who are weaponizing this ESG narrative
to try to actually take over various
companies various financial markets and
simply create Havoc chaos us and
uncertainty in the market Tesla the
company that is literally
revolutionizing renewable energy and is
bringing in all sorts of electric
vehicle adoption into the market by far
the single most important company in the
United States to go ahead and push this
forward they got kicked out of the ESG
index just on its face this is
absolutely insane Exxon Mobil is
considered a top 10 ESG company and
Tesla's not even on the list if you
don't see what's happening open your
eyes start paying attention because what
is important is that we cannot allow
extremists to take on these types of
arguments and to Simply start bullying
the good actors the entrepreneurs and
the investors at the end of the day the
free market is the referee and the free
market is determined exactly who's doing
right by the environment and who isn't
at the end of the day nobody believes
this nonsense and eventually the ESG
scam and the Mirage is all gonna fall
apart hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this Channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time